I called her and she didn't really say
anything alright guys we are finally
learning what Kylie said to Jordan
following the cheating scandal she was
just like you know crying the whole time
and I was just telling her I'm like
scared if you know like I bet you're
capable of waking up the next morning
with a smile on your face and then I
pretty much told her exactly what we've
been talking about like you weren't
thinking about true you were not not
Chloe not me but you weren't thinking
about yourself Kylie shares the details
while chatting with Khloe and Kim in
this new clip from Sunday's episode of
Keeping Up with the Kardashians you
could do whatever when it affects like
my family me then that's when like it's
a problem we also hear Chloe's take
Tristan we've all known what he's
capable of look what he did when I was 9
months pregnant
but I knew who he was I never in a
million years thought that's what
believed it when it was online everyone
know what it believes it and gam had a
lot to say too but I also think that the
tone of not ever saying sorry like I
would have been on Khloe's doorstep
bawling my eyes out being like mmhmm I
don't know what the I was doing holy SH
I'm looking innit of course this all
went down back in February but it's just
now playing out on the show Orden opened
up about her side of the story on red
Tabletalk after the incident on the way
out he did kiss me
man we mean by kiss it's just no passion
no nothing on the way up he just kissed
me and it was like a kiss on the lips
but no tongue kiss no making out dad
nothing and et was with her after this
trailer dropped just days ago I'm just
like what were you thinking it just
sucks it has to be so public you know
everyone has their truth in their story
and so you just go with go with it
everyone has the right to speak their
truth now this is just the tip of the
iceberg we should see everything play
out during the two-part season finale of
the show starting Sunday Kris Jenner
told E to you what it's like reliving at
the scandal and it's not easy I think
one of the things that has made the
success of the show is that we are you
know show those vulnerabilities and
we're also
transparent and you do see how it
actually unfolded and what happened
because everybody thinks they know the
whole story and they don't so I think
that's the interesting thing is just
watching how we all handle you know
these situations and and what we all
learn from it
all right so will you be tuning in on
Sunday and what do you make of this
whole story let me know and for all the
latest on the Kardashians keep it locked
to all things
ét until next time I'm Katie Krause and
bye for now
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]